he'd like me born in Brooklyn New York I
loved watching him play basketball at
st. John's and then he spent some time
with the hometown New York
knickerbockers and you soon to see him
in the last stance on the Indiana Pacers
team at Jordan would always clash with
and he's one of the lead voices in the
NBA today and long with Jeff Van Gundy
Mike Breen bringing you the NBA Finals
every single year on the NBA on ESPN
Mark Jackson here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you mark I'm doing well thanks
for having me you and your family say we
are knock on wood how about you doing
well thank you glad to hear that what do
you think of the last dance mark you
learning anything watching this
documentary I think it's must-see TV you
know I said you know watching the first
episode that I could watch the whole
thing all the way through I think it's
an outstanding inside look at you know
greatness firsthand and for the first
time ever Michael Jordan is allowed the
curtains to be drawn back a little bit
which I think encourages and inspires
and it also you know he's gonna take
some hits because of it also because
it's the first time and there's the
folks that can't comprehend his level of
intensity of competitive drive so while
you were on the the Knicks teams in the
very beginning of those battles with
Jordan what was that like mark well I
think you know I was in two game sevens
against that Bulls trying that Bulls run
in 92 next team previous to the you know
a year before Charles Smith and Knicks
had him on the Brinks but that 92 team
we had we took him to a game seven we
were loaded top to bottom we were very
deep very talented
two guys in each position we want him
down and at that time in 1992 Michael
Jordan you know pretty much
single-handedly beat us he willed them
to the victory in 98 where my paces team
was different they were more of a
complete basketball team and had help
from top to bottom so competing against
him and seeing you know the conversation
we're seeing today
about his personality nice guy or not
where do you rest on that subject mark I
can say this you know I've been around
them quite a bit I can remember years
ago going on a Nike trip with my parents
and and my family and his parents and
his family along with some other guys in
the league
totally class-act I mean every time been
around him great guy I just think that
he has a competitive Drive where he's
willing to do whatever it takes to win
in basketball and life and anything he's
playing he's been great to me so I that
without a doubt he's a nice guy now he
was open he said it comes with the price
winning now I don't agree that if you
don't understand that then you never won
because I there's not just one way of
winning but it's one way of winning for
Michael Jordan and it worked and it
worked effectively and put them in in
position to be the greatest player of
all time well in terms of being the
greatest player of all time there's
there's no doubt about that but you see
the struggle that so many of his
teammates had with him who was the
toughest teammate you ever had mark I've
had tough teammates but not like that
don't tell me I can't grab a bite on the
plane because you know somebody I didn't
play well anything like that's not gonna
happen um you you have tough teammates
in a mindset of Pat Ewing and a mindset
of Charles Oakley in the mindset of
Reggie Miller is different brands of
toughness it's not just privado
sometimes toughness is you know are you
suiting up every every night are you
ready to face every battle every
challenge are you leading in different
positions whether you're coming off a 50
point game are you coming off of you
know a game where another guy gave you
50 so toughness I define a little
different but there's no question about
his brand of leadership just looking at
it I think I'd like to get a love an
example of who else were the leaders
because you don't just have one way of
leader leading leading a basketball team
for example the teams that I was on
whether if you don't make team but I
Bulls team I mean that Nick team when I
face a team we certainly had leadership
and Patrick you
Reggie Miller but I humbly submit I was
a I was the leader in the formal
verbally vocally holding eyes
accountable given instructions and
things like that sort of different
brands of leadership I'd like to see a
better a better look of who else was
leading in uniform during that run mark
Jackson here on the Rich Eisen show so
watching this documentary what emotions
pop up for you mark well I had the
privilege of doing a you know a detailed
analysis of game seven so I watched it
pretty much went over it and you know
prior to that I did a couple interviews
and they asked me questions
excuse me about different situations in
the game and I couldn't even I couldn't
even give an answer because I didn't
remember I didn't recall but watching
the game brought back you know sharp
memories and just reminded me pretty
much of how close we had you know
arguably the greatest team assemblee
that's ever been assembled how close we
had them to on the verge of losing we're
up three with six minutes to go on the
road in game seven with a jump ball
between Michael Jordan and a seven-foot
4 inch Center
Rick's Mitch and we lose it Steve Kerr
gets a wide open three off of a broken
play ties the ballgame and the rest is
history but just just the thought of the
great team that we had the great times
that we had and we have nothing to be
ashamed of they're not allowed to be a
proud of I think it's inside look of not
just their greatness but how they were
challenged
well I guess we're looking over the
steering wheel and a brief bit that's
probably gonna be episode nine coming up
this weekend with the Pacers versus the
the Bulls in the in the last dance and
you know one thing that just kind of
struck me over this past episodes mark
was just the undying respect obviously
that you would have for somebody like
Jordan and who he represents and what he
stands for but you know in his world of
competition you know it was all Chum in
the water for him and then I'm watching
a whole
bunch of players you know play pick-up
basketball with him on the set of Space
Jam and I'm sitting there thinking why
don't they have the opposite point of
view of saying why in the world am i
helping out Michael Jordan get back into
shape you know what I'm saying
yeah that's a great point but I think
the mindset of the players is not I'm
helping out Michael Jordan get in better
shape I'm getting a peak of greatness a
peak at greatness and I'm also
sharpening my tools getting better
around not just Michael Jordan because
it's not a one-man band
his greatness all throughout the league
and there's levels to it but just sharp
iron sharpens iron and you get an
opportunity to be in the midst of a
workout facility with the best in the
land and no better place then to be
challenged and to compete and then they
get an inside look of just what makes
this guy tick not just him but but
across the board when you're in a gym
with I mean you look at that video alone
that was some that was some big-time
pickup run oh yeah I mean some of the
some of the best footage we've seen in
the last answers not only that game but
obviously the Monte Carlo practice for
for the dream team and and and all that
mark I mean it's just been great just to
seeing that that stuff on the inside and
you're already hearing some of the
conversation that Jordan that there's no
Jordan in the NBA today even LeBron
being as great as he is he doesn't have
that similar killer instinct that Jordan
is displaying right here how would you
handle that having such a front-row seat
of watching the bronze greatness unfold
in his generation mark I will say this
when it's all said and done LeBron James
will have the best basketball NBA
basketball career that has ever been the
best basketball career with that being
said I'm saying he's gonna be the
all-time leading scorer he's gonna be a
top-five assist man in history of the
game with a bunch of other accolades
that we don't have enough time for me to
to to go through but Michael Jordan is
the best player that's ever played the
game I think that the difference is that
mentality that killer mentality I think
I've said it already wrong on record
there's only two guys that I face and I
faced the greats and and this is not a
shot towards them but there's only two
guys that I face that I felt like it
to die on the floor and that's Michael
Jordan Kobe Bryant just different
mentalities and and and different work
ethic I put them in position you want
them on your team and that's not a shot
at and the Bron James or anybody else
that's just given credit to those who
guys would you have wanted to play with
those two guys without a doubt without a
doubt without a doubt that's that that's
it to me that's that's a trick question
because I'm not afraid to work I'm not
afraid to lead I'm not afraid to
challenge I think they're great
teammates at the same time what you
wanted what you want most from a
teammate is when the lights turn on you
I know what I'm a gift from them and
without a doubt with those two guys you
knew it was gonna be a hundred a hundred
percent effort energy and intention so I
mean again just diving into this because
I think this is going to be the
conversation once the documentary ends
next Sunday and we're gonna come on the
air Monday on this show and so many
others talking about who's the greatest
of all time from Jordan and LeBron
that'll be one conversation another one
will be Bulls team that we just saw and
the Lakers team that Phil Jackson took
over as coach with Shaq and Kobe so on
and so forth I think that will be the
conversation we're having nationally a
week from now so I'm kind of
front-loading that conversation with you
right now mark Jackson in in the manner
of why when you say that that LeBron of
the greatest career but Jordans the
greatest player and the difference is
that he didn't have the same mentality
that Jordan and Kobe had then why why do
you think LeBron does not have that when
he has certainly every other gifted that
those two other players had well a
couple things I'm not gonna you know
take Kareem abdul-jabbar out of the
conversation can you know I think his
greatness gets overlooked so I'm not
gonna fast forward to just LeBron and
Jay and and Michael so I think there's a
there's a list of guys that's in the
discussion when you look at will
chambers numbers also it's it's a blows
your mind but I'll say that it's not a
it's not a knock at LeBron in
automatically when you say the mentality
of Kobe and Michael people fast forward
and drive right up to LeBron's garage
I'm saying everybody that I've ever seen
played a game in the history of this
game there's only two guys so not just
LeBron every single body else other than
Michael and Kobe didn't have that
mentality including me so it's not a
knock and I was and I feel I feel like
I'm outstanding competitor and I want to
win but I'm not willing to lose my life
on the court for the game of basketball
that's a whole different mentality so
it's not a shot at the Brawn and it's a
credit really to his greatness and is a
credit to his overall mentality I think
when you when you looked at Michael
Annett the last dance when you looked at
him talk and get emotional he's saying
it comes with a price he's saying and I
don't mean losing friends he lost
relationships you see he I'm sure he's
looking Sam well I could have been a
better father I could have been a better
husband I could have been a better bad
but I was you know driven down one lane
with one mindset in one goal he's
opening up LeBron James is I don't I
don't I don't think at the end of day is
gonna have that same story now he's
gonna say I got I sacrificed a little
bit much and I could have been a better
man father a husband and all those
things like all of us have but not to
the degree that Michael Jordan feels it
and expressed it when we saw tears
coming down the side of his face mark I
appreciate the time but before I let you
go we had Larry Brown on the other day
because it was the 18th anniversary of
the practice rant and it was also the
25th anniversary of Reggie Miller doing
in the garden what he did to the Knicks
and Spike Lee and speaking is a born in
Brooklyn native New Yorker from Staten
Island watching st. John's it was tough
to see you on the other team that day
mark very very I've got the crying rich
meme going on right now man like
seriously like you know and then
obviously seeing Mullin in a Pacers
uniform too you know and you and Mullen
again I just you know so st. John's
teams man were just amazing and just the
teams of my youth and who you
represented and what you did and
man I just wanted those moments in the
garden for you in the NYX uniform I
would have loved it you know especially
after 92 taking them to Bulls the game
seven I think if we keep that team
together we ultimately win a
championship but those were fun times
and just correct you no one knows 25
years ago not 2020 yeah I would say 20
at 25 right yeah
where'd you mellow put on an incredible
performance down the stretch of a
ballgame that going down as history is
one of the best moments of all time in
the brightest lights - but sire Browns a
Hall of Fame coach Hall of Fame guy I
had a blast playing foam I'm talking
about Chris Mullen I'm not the NBA
player for 17 years had I not gone to
st. John's and watched firsthand Chris
Mullin worked his tail off in a gym I
was a gym rat he was a gym technician
turned me and my mind said totally to a
different level
no kidding was anything that Reggie said
to spike safe for work to recount and
what was it like having Larry Bird as a
coach it was great because we came off
of Larry Brown like I said it was a Hall
of Fame coach but a different mentality
his foot is on the gas bill at all times
he's always looking to teach and and
nurture and complain about something
when a Larry Bird just came in and just
wanted to lead us to guide us and allow
us to run to show and and was fine with
no ego he didn't have to overdo who he
was he was outstanding coach and just
what the doctor ordered for our
basketball team and coach Luiz still
still around right concept still around
still around doing great is unbelievable
I look at my phone and I see it ring and
it's coach counter second and he talks
shop asking about all the kids in the
family and he saw the thing I loved
about it he made a promise my mom and
dad all these years ago and he he didn't
lie one time he's a he's a Hall of Fame
coach football partly a Hall of Fame
Yuma being mark thanks for the time and
going down memory lane man
really appreciate it and I'd love to
have you back on as the NBA knock on
wood gets back into action sooner rather
than later we hope anytime and thanks
for having me keep up the awesome work
and stay so it means a lot to hear that
from you mark thank you that's mark
Jackson
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here